في وقت مبكر من الوباء عندما
بدأت الشركات في إعادة فتح
العديد من حواجز زجاج شبكي مثبتة من
أجل تقليل التعرض للمخاطر
مثل covid19 ولكن اتضح أن هذه
الحواجز المادية
قد لا تكون فعالة كما كنا نأمل في
حين أنها مغرية
ومريحة للغاية توفر إحساسًا زائفًا
بالأمان
بالطبع ، هناك مخاوف عملية
فيما
يتعلق بتحديد موقع قسم زجاجي ،
ومدى ارتفاعه ، ومدى اتساعه ، وعدد مرات
تنظيفه ،
تقول الدكتورة وفاء الصادر ، أستاذة
علم الأوبئة في جامعة كولومبيا ، إن
هذه هي المشكلة نفسها مع دروع الوجه البلاستيكية.
أكثر
ملاءمة وأسهل في ارتدائها ،
فهي ليست بديلاً
للتباعد الجسدي وأقنعة الوجه ،
فنحن نعلم أنه بالطبع يمكن للفيروس نفسه
أن يكون في جزيئات أصغر بكثير
ويمكنه الالتفاف حول
زجاجي كما لم
يثبت علميًا أنه يحمي
الهباء الجوي  قطرات تنتشر من
العطس
والسعال والكلام ولكن لا داعي
لرمي تلك الحواجز البلاستيكية  ay
بدلاً من ذلك ، من الأفضل استخدامها بالإضافة
إلى أغطية الوجه والمسافة الجسدية
لمسافة ستة أقدام على الأقل في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم.
لكن ليس لديه أي دليل على أن
كلمة حصانة تعني شيئًا
يتفق الخبراء الطبيون على أنها تعني
شيئًا
ما ، ولهذا السبب يتوخى الدكتور ساجو ماثيو الحذر الشديد
بشأن استخدام تلك الكلمة ، فلن
أستخدم كلمة حصانة
مع أطمع 19. ذلك لأن المناعة ضد
هذا الفيروس هي  شيء ما
زلنا لا نعرف الكثير عنه ليس هناك
معنى أننا نشعر بأننا نشعر علميًا
أنه يمكنك في الواقع أن تكون محصنًا من
الطمع 19. نحن نعلم أنه يمكنك بناء
مستوى معين من
المناعة لبضعة أشهر ، لكننا أيضًا
لديهم دراسات أظهرت أنه بعد
شهرين
تنخفض المناعة وهناك
حالات موثقة لأشخاص
أصيبوا بكورونا 19 ثم أصيبوا مرة أخرى ،
فإن مركز السيطرة على الأمراض لديه الحذر على وجه التحديد
الناس لا يفترضون أنهم محصنون
قائلين إن المناعة لم يتم
تأسيسها بعد ، لكن هذا شيء
يعمل عليه العلماء في المعهد الوطني الأمريكي للسرطان
الذي أطلق للتو شبكة العلوم المصلية
لفيروس covid19 أو cerronet في ندوة عبر الإنترنت ،
نائب المدير الرئيسي دوغلاس لوي
يقول
إنهم سوف  أعمل للإجابة على عدد من
الأسئلة وما تم وصفه بأنه
أكبر جهد منسق للأمة لدراسة
الاستجابة المناعية
لفيروس covid19 ، وآمل
أنه بحلول نهاية هذا العام سيكون
لدينا إجابات جزئية على الأقل ، أنا بريت
كونواي
أبلغ
عن  خرجت مراكز مكافحة الأمراض
والوقاية منها بتحذير جديد
يرسم رابطًا آخر بين
الشباب وبعض
النقاط الساخنة الـ 19
المرغوبة في البلاد ، ووجد مركز السيطرة على الأمراض أن نتائج الاختبارات الإيجابية
بدأت عمومًا في الارتفاع بين الأشخاص الذين
تقل أعمارهم عن 25 عامًا
قبل شهر تقريبًا من ظهور المنطقة.
حدد الباحثون نقطة ساخنة لمطعم covet 19
حيث أكد الباحثون
على الحاجة إلى مخاطبة
الشباب  تفشي ping spark ،
أظهر استطلاع محلي في إحدى مقاطعات ويسكونسن
أن
الشباب قلقون من أنهم سيشعرون
بالغرابة أو يخرجون من الخارج وهم يرتدون
قناعًا يبدأ أولاً وقبل كل شيء مع
عودة طلاب الجامعات إلى الجامعات
والكليات ونشهد انتقالًا كبيرًا
هناك ثم  ينتقل
إلى السكان البالغين الأكبر سنًا هذا
الأسبوع ، حيث سجلت الولايات المتحدة أكبر عدد
من
حالات الطمع في يوم واحد في ما يقرب من
شهرين ، وهناك عدد قليل من الولايات
التي أبلغت عن انخفاض في
الحالات الجديدة هذا الأسبوع في آخر مرة
في أوهايو ، حيث توقع مايك ديوين
حدوث انخفاض في الحالات الجديدة.
الشتاء القاسي للغاية مع كل من دخول
المستشفى ومتوسط عمر المرضى الذين يرتفع عد
هم في كل رقم يسير في الاتجاه الخطأ في
لشمال الشرقي ، حيث ارتفع المتوسط المتحرك للحال
ت الجديدة من 8 سبتمبر إلى 8 أكتوبر بنسبة
ذهلة بلغت 91 في المائ
.  يحذر فريق عمل فيروس كوروتا من أن
أحد الأسباب المحتملة هو
الانتشار الفيروسي الصامت بدون أعراض بين
العائلات في المجتمعات المحلية  يرجى إحضار نفس الانضباط الذي تجلبه إلى الأماكن العامة في منزلك والحد من المشاركة مع الآخرين خارج أسرتك المباشرة في أجزاء من ملكات مدينة نيويورك وأحياء بروكلين. احتج أعضاء مجموعات covid هذا الأسبوع من الأحياء اليهودية الأرثوذكسية على القيود الأخيرة التي تم وضعها للحد من انتشار covet 19 على الرغم من أن لقاح الفيروس لا يزال قيد العمل ، يقول أحد مسؤولي مركز السيطرة على الأمراض إن الخطط الرسمية لتوزيعه بمجرد توفره هي على الهدف لتلبية الموعد النهائي في 16 أكتوبر. في بعض الولايات وفي العاصمة مثل العديد من ستيفاني هيدالغو ، تحملت بهدوء التحدي المتمثل في إزعاج العيش في ظل جائحة ولكنها أرادت أن تفعل المزيد ، وكانت هذه طريقة بالنسبة لي لأتحكم في الموقف لأشعر وكأنني في أكثر أو في مكان أقل ميؤوسًا منه في عالم أقل ميؤوسًا منه وأكون على ما يرام ، يمكنني القيام بذلك لأجعله أفضل اخترت عدم التواجد فيه
خوف ،
لذا تطوعت
للإصابة بالفيروس التاجي عمداً
كنت أرتجف ولكن بعد ذلك فقط دون أن
أعرف أنني كتبت اسمي للتو
وكنت مثل دعنا نذهب لنهتز
وأريد أن أكون جزءًا منه نعم
لأنه يمكن أن يكون مخيفًا مثل
من المحتمل
أن تتعرض للفيروس ، نعم
أيضًا أليستر فريزر حريص جدًا على الإصابة ،
لقد تلقيت للتو البريد الإلكتروني الذي يساعده في
إدارة حملة التوظيف ،
وقد سجل ستيفاني في
يوم واحد قريبًا من العثور على متطوعين حتى الآن
عشرات  الآلاف حول
العالم وقد ضغطت على حكومة المملكة المتحدة
للاستفادة منها من
خلال بحث يحتمل أن تكون محفوفة بالمخاطر.أستيقظ
أفكر في تشارلز الصدفة
وأعود إلى الفراش أفكر في
تجارب التحدي التي تنطوي على تحدي إعطاء الشباب
الأصحاء لقاحًا محتملاً
مثل هذا اللقاح  تم تطويره من قبل
الكلية الإمبراطورية في لندن ثم
اختباره لاحقًا عن طريق إعطاء جرعات متعمدة
من أنصار الفيروس
يقولون إنه أسرع من انتظار
خروج الأشخاص
الخاضعين للاختبار  تم طرحه على فيروس معين في
العالم الحقيقي
مع العديد من اللقاحات السرية التي تم
تطويرها من خلال 19 لقاحًا ، يعتقد بعض العلماء أن
تجارب التحدي
يمكن أن تساعد في تحديد أفضلها في
وقت أقرب من
خلال تحمل هذا الخطر الصغير على نفسي ،
يمكنني أن أعرف أنه يحتمل حماية
الآلاف من الأشخاص الآخرين منك
أن تصاب بالعدوى
دون موافقتها ، يقول النقاد إن
التجارب التحدي لها
استخدام محدود لأن الشباب
الأصحاء الذين يشاركون
لا يمثلون السكان الأوسع
الذين تم استخدامهم ضد فيروسات أخرى ،
مرحبًا بكم في غلوكان ، شكرًا
لك على الحجر الصحي ، ثم
نعم نعم هذا  عبارة عن فيديو خاص
بشركة من منشأة في لندن يقوم بتجنيد
الأشخاص ويعرضهم بشكل صارم
لاختبار
لقاحات الأنفلونزا ، فلدينا
سجل أمان رائع نفتخر به جميعًا ،
ولكن هناك دائمًا مخاطر خاصة
مع فيروس جديد
قتل بالفعل أكثر من مليون
يقول الناس وعلماء الأوبئة إنه من المحتمل
أن تكون هناك حاجة إلى بعض المتطوعين
لمجموعة التحكم  تأكد من أن جرعة الفيروس يمكن أن تسبب
المرض ،
فهذا يعني أنهم سيتعرضون للفيروس
التاجي دون
تلقي لقاح ، فإن الاحتمال
الحقيقي لإلحاق الضرر بالمتطوعين
سيتم فحصه عن كثب من قبل
المنظمين ، حيث يتعين على تجربة التحدي
أن تقدم حجة مقنعة
بأن الفوائد التي ستعود على المتطوعين
تفوق المجتمع بشكل كبير على المخاطر وأن
هذا الدليل أو تلك البيانات لا يمكن
تحقيقه بطريقة أبسط وأكثر أمانًا
يتم تعويض الأشخاص المختبرين وتجارب التحدي
ماليًا ،
لكن والد أليستر يعلم أن هذا لا
يحفز ابنه ،
فهو في طليعة العلم والتكنولوجيا ،
إنه شيء يستفيد منه  الآخرون ، إنه
شيء شجاع إلى حد ما ، إنه شيء
مختلف قليلاً
وهذا هو باختصار
لأكون صادقًا تمامًا ، فأنا لا أهتم حقًا
بما يقوله ،
فأنا أفعل ما يعجبني عنصرًا
أساسيًا في أي تجربة تحدي 19 سرية
ستكون المثالية المحددة لـ
متطوعيها الشباب
فيل بلاك سي إن إن لندن